what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again with
another seven deadly sins video
i got a lot of requests to do an updated
video for every sin rank for weakest the
strongest
since the manga series is over now so
here we are i'll be looking at all the
sins that they're strongest and ranking
them for your entertainment
if you do enjoy seeing some deadly sins
videos on this channel and want to keep
them coming then the best thing you can
do is smash that like button and share
this video with any cultured sds fans
that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future seven deadly sins videos
as you wait for those videos to drop
check out our huge seven deadly sins
playlist where we got videos about the
commandments about power levels about
backstories and much
much more link in the description
obviously there will be manga spoilers
since i'll be using the most up-to-date
evidence
so you've been warned if you're an anime
only also as we move forward keep in
mind that all of the sins are strong and
useful in their own way
and have their own strengths and
weaknesses in other words i'm not trying
to hate on your favorite sin the sins
are at their best when they're working
together and complimenting each other
but for fun i'm going to be ranking them
remember this is just my opinion and if
you disagree that's totally cool
let me know how you'd rank them and why
in the comments at number 7 i have the
goatson of lust
gother since gother is a doll he doesn't
age and can practically live on forever
furthermore he doesn't feel physical
pain and he can be fixed
even after some of the most severe
attacks as well so in short he's super
resilient
his highest recorded power level was 35
400 and that was after he regained his
memories
i expected him to get another
significant power upgrade but we didn't
really get one he did get a
self-destruct device implanted into him
by merlin for the device
merlin uses magic extract from escondar
sunshine ability and mixes into four
elements of destruction and then
maximizes the destructive power by using
her own magic infinity the explosion can
exterminate all living matter in a
radius of 10 miles from the user
so it could be considered to be one of
the most op attacks in the seven deadly
sins
however gother would have to sacrifice
his own life to use it and it's not even
his own original power but power that
relies on merlin's knowledge
combined with her and eskenor's
abilities for those reasons the
self-destruct attack is not enough for
me to place gother any higher on this
list
gother excels in being able to read
people's minds
in being able to rewrite their memories
and in being able to create illusions
however we just haven't seen these
abilities being super effective in
one-on-one settings against the
strongest of opponents and for that
reason
although the potential for gothic's
powers are cool i'm keeping him in 7th
place
notably his powers were useful in
freeing mile from the influence of the
ten commandments in freeing meliotis
from the demon king and so on however
he's mainly used it to help rather than
to straight up beat opponents
for instance in the case of the demon
king bond still needed to fight him from
the outside and gother could help
motivate
meliotis with his power but he couldn't
just send the demon king out of his body
in sixth place we have deanne the
serpent son of envy she's the strongest
member of the giant clan and we saw some
very impressive feats from her during
the battle against the demon king when
he was in zeldas body
she succeeds in single-handedly using
her powers to separate demon king's
eldritches from the lake
which was supplying him with important
magical powers she uses her earth
bending to push him around and to create
a large lifted platform under his feet
which is separating him from the magic
lake so he can't replenish his power her
highest power level which comes from a
data book was at least 50 000
and that's before the end of the series
it's safe to assume that it's
significantly higher by the time she
stands up to the demon king now this was
not a prolonged battle or anything with
the demon king and escanor took over
after she created the raid's platform i
really don't think that the and would
have done well in a prolonged one-on-one
fight with the demon king
still though she got to show off her
powers and had her time to shine in
physical combat
in a way that gother didn't for that
reason i'm putting her here in sixth
place
next up in fifth place i have merlin
merlin is a fun one to examine because
her highest recorded power level is even
lower than gothur's it's only 4710
and it was given to us near the
beginning of the series however that
power level does a horrible job of
reflecting what merlin is capable of
merlin as mentioned is the one that
created the bomb inside gother meaning
that she could create more like it
and even use them herself if she wanted
to she has the added benefit of even
being able to teleport meaning she could
potentially leave the bomb and teleport
far away where she'd be unscathed this
is all hypothetical though so let's
actually look at some of her impressive
feats in the manga one of the things
that amazed me the most
was how she single-handedly beat both
chandler and cusack who had power levels
of at least 173 thousand
and 168 000 respectively she used the
perfect combination of strategy and
spells in order to overpower them
however she can't do this with every
opponent
as we saw when chandler and kusak fused
into the original demon
and merlin could no longer compete
merlin is especially useful
in team battles where she could use her
magic to amplify the power of her allies
or even to fuse their attacks together
in one combined attack
still though the w she pulled off
against cusack and chandler showed that
merlin is no slouch when it comes to
one-on-one
or even two-on-one battles and i don't
think gother nor diane
could have done as well as she did next
up we have king
the grizzly sin of sloth his full-grown
wings and elvis hair gave him a huge
power
power-up
mile with the power of the commandments
was flexing on everyone present even
before he absorbed all four
but after he absorbed all four his power
level was over two hundred thousand and
everyone present was freaking out and
sweating buckets
combined attacks from gother diane and
pre-transformation king were useless
against him but then pushed to the edge
king grows his full-sized wings and
becomes the strongest fairy king in
history
after the transformation he can use
multiple spirit spirit forms at the same
time the
eighth form allows him to protect the
others from miles attacks
the second form which takes the form of
a buff and many armed bear
lets him punch around mael and i could
go on but you get the point
we see during this battle that he can at
the very least use four spirit sphere
forms at the same time
and that's saying a lot because they are
all significantly stronger
than they used to be now yes smile was
not in great shape since he'd been
fighting and the commandments were
messing with him but the fact remains
he was still wrecking everyone prior to
king's transformation
and we are told that miles spent all of
his energy and that he's being devoured
by the commandments only after king has
already flexed on him multiple times
so nothing should be taken away from
king's accomplishments in this battle
in the meantime escanor and merlin have
been fighting the original demon aka the
fusion
of the op demons cusack and chandler the
original demon was actually their
original form
this dude is definitely stronger than
mile with four commandments but
king with his new powers and from a long
distance manages to keep him busy
from such a distance king can only use
one form and it wastes
too much magic at too quick a rate so
it's not ideal
but still the fact that he could do so
well during his first try is amazing
he may well have beat the original demon
2 if zeldas did not use the demon king's
resistance to magic to cancel out his
massive sunflower attack he then
proceeds to occupy zeldris long enough
for mile
with sunshine to show up and wreck the
original demon however by the time the
demon king is resurrected in meliotis's
body
neither king nor mile with sunshine can
do anything to him
yes king has exhausted a lot of his
magic by this point but it still seems
like the demon king is far out of his
league which is why i had to put king
here in 4th place
willow bond who is at number 3 on this
list bond the fox's son of greed has
probably
my favorite transformation in the whole
series
i love his character but we can't
pretend like he didn't lag behind in
power
at least in the beginning bond was
completely powerless to help his best
friend meliotis
when estorosa was killing him immortal
or not bond was weak
physically speaking however that all
changed when he went to purgatory in
purgatory there is freezing burning
poisoning in the worst environments you
can imagine
usually human bodies would break down
soon enough
but because of his immortality bond's
body kept regenerating and eventually
adapted to the harsh
environment this allowed him to make
better use of his snatch ability as well
which lets him not only steal physical
objects
but strength stamina and even speed from
his opponents as well
the stronger his body becomes the more
power he can take from his enemy
i also want to add that bond's mental
strength should not be overlooked
many others would have gone completely
insane even with a regenerating body
before ever making it out of purgatory
however bond's mental strength allowed
him to endure and to eventually come
back
as a much much stronger character as i
mentioned heavy hitters like king with
full grown wings and mile with sunshine
were powerless against the demon king
and meliotis body
but not bon bon was quick enough to save
hawke before the demon king noticed what
was going on and then he proceeded to
duke it out with him
like an equal bond became strong enough
to do what no one else present could
he fought the demon king long enough so
that meliotis and the others could help
kick the demon king outside of meliotis
body from within
he even delivered the finishing punch
and in the process helped save his
friend from a much stronger opponent
than esterosa
in this way he fully redeemed himself
and even though he traded his
immortality in exchange for elaine's
life before the fight it's clear that
bond has never been stronger he was fine
after the fight with the demon king and
managed to recover with no lasting
damage
furthermore bond with his sacred
treasure was also the most useful when
it came to the threat of the countless
baby endura
spreading across the world only he could
have finished off so many and so quickly
if not for him enduros would still be
wreaking havoc across britannia
so yeah that is why bond is so high and
despite not being in first place
strength wise his character arc is
definitely my favorite of all
next up we have escanor the lion son of
pride esquinor managed to do the
impossible he surpassed the power of the
one
when he entered the one ultimate in the
battle against demon king zeldras
and just to make it clear when i say
demon king zeldras
i mean when the demon king was in
control of zeldras's body
esquinor entered this form after the one
minute during noon past
by converting his own life force into
magical power this form has the biggest
of drawbacks
in that it is cutting away at your life
while you use it and
after the battle eskner passes away
because he sacrificed so much of his
life force but before he passed away he
did quite well against demon king
zeldras and punched him around quite a
bit too
we can't know for sure how the
one-on-one fight would have turned out
if the sins didn't jump into help the
demon king said and i quote
enough of this farce be gone when he
launched an attack that meliodas blocked
for escondor
furthermore he was landing some hits on
escondur and
esknor's energy was running out quick
not to mention that as we figure out
later even if you kill the demon king
since he's like a god in this world
he'll regenerate eventually
unless you trade an equally godly power
to erase him for good
for these reasons i think escanor could
have done relatively well
on his own against the demon king until
his life energy ran out but i don't
think he would have been able to kill
the demon king once and for all
before his life ran out that had to be
meliotis
still though it seems clear to me that
with the one ultimate eskinor was able
to pass
all of the others in power which is why
i'm putting him in second place on this
list
and in first place we have our captain
meliotis the dragon set of wrath
most of this section will be about me
explaining why i put meliotis above
escondar the one ultimate
since i'm sure many would have liked to
see him on the top of this list
however no matter how many times i
consider it and from how many angles
i always have to give first place to
meliotis and i'll explain why meliotis
was the
heir to the demon king and he had the
same godly power
in fact once he unlocked his own demon
king powers he could no longer even stay
in the human realm
he was too powerful the weather started
going haywire
and the world could potentially be
destroyed by his mere presence
that's definitely not something that's
been said about any other sin
then when it came to defeating the demon
king meliotis enhanced the combined
attack multiple times with full counter
and it was he who eventually launched it
at the demon king and finished him off
however as i previously mentioned the
commandments didn't disappear
merlin explains that they are dealing
with a god and that defeating him
won't completely destroy him at most
he'll regain
his original strength in a few decades
or centuries
this is when meliotis changes into his
demon king form
at witnessing this form in power zelda
straight up says that it's even greater
than the demon kings
then melioda sacrifices his demon king
powers in order to finally destroy the
commandments once and for all
and conveniently he can now stay in the
human world as well because he no longer
has that godly power
in order to destroy the demon king for
good it would stand to reason that
meliodas had to sacrifice an equal or
greater amount of power and he still has
plenty of power to spare
afterwards this is the dude that
effortlessly wiped the kingdom off the
face of the earth
before he even unlocked his demon king
powers so we can only imagine how much
damage demon king meliotis could have
caused
if he wasn't a good guy zelda said that
at the very least he could rule the
entire underworld with that power
through fear
and unlike escanor meliotis didn't even
need to convert life force energy
into magic power to reach that level he
could have maintained that power
and lived on for a long long time in the
demon realm without any issues
and the power would have been accessible
all the time not just at specific times
of the day
at his strongest he was not only
stronger than the other sins he was
stronger than the demon king himself a
being who is nothing less than a god
within the seven deadly sins world for
all of these reasons hands down i gotta
give the number one spot to the demonic
captain himself
meliotis and that is it for this one if
you did enjoy this video and want to see
more seven deadly sins videos like it
then the best thing you can do is smash
that like button and share this video
with your cultured comrades
if you haven't be sure to subscribe this
is crucial hit that notification bell
and select all or you will miss
future seven deadly sins videos let me
know if you would have ranked the sense
differently and why
and let me know what video topics you
would like me to cover next
and as you wait for those videos to drop
check out our huge seminally since
playlist where we got videos about the
commandments
power levels backstories and much much
more
i also want to thank all of you because
the channel has been growing faster than
ever
and it's unreal we passed 950
000 subscribers and are actually
approaching 1 million subscribers
and it's all thanks to you guys and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord twego himself
alpha sigma and are the one to patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans
stephen and grotta the world acquire
respect pate heffa jonathan king rathu
and aura
liam thompson emperor otaku thomas jones
ken mono and admirath and our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only gilgamesh
who's the current most donated overall
champion of the world
nothing but a fan kings eldris anatoly
kazowski angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor hirokami and water bonnie parks
jason wilson florian
joanne garcia steelers mcshamus jessica
kayla fond
dudley saint and stern hawkins thank you
all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
animeapro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life
and of course thank memes so check out
patreon.com animeopro link in the
description if you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking the blue join button next to
the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you